somewhere in the north sea miles off the
coast of scotland a revolution is about
to take place
oil and gas fields which once pump
fossil fuels out of the ground are now
promising to help solve climate change
it is a remarkable controversial claim
but it goes to the very heart of the
race to net zero
to see why we need to chase these
underwater pipes connecting the rigs and
oil fields back to where they meet land
this is one of the main pipelines taking
natural gas from the north sea all the
way through
into the grid so 10 to 20 percent of
what goes into your boiler into the
electricity system it's passing
right under my hands but that is only
the start of the story
because the plan is to take carbon
dioxide from various industrial
processes
pressurize it liquefy it put it into
this pipeline and send it down under the
ground
into the north sea that at least is the
idea gas is coming from the north sea
it's been cleaned up and it's been sent
into the national grid to go to
everybody's homes around the country i
think in 30 50 years time you're going
to see still that process continuing but
what you'll see is in reverse a carbon
capture and storage facility which is
then sending the co2 that is captured
from this gas offshore to make the gas
effectively carbon zero and they will in
addition piggy piggybacking on all of
that will be a the manufacturer of
hydrogen which of course is a net zero
fuel
but you're probably wondering isn't this
just another way of fossil fuel
companies carrying on extracting fossil
fuels that's a really important point to
stress
that
even at net zero we will continue to
need
industry will continue to need oil and
gas and ccs is a technology that
actually helps us reduce the emissions
from
those
industries that still require oil and
gas
so how does carbon capture actually work
well there are all sorts of industrial
processes power stations cement
manufacturer and so on that create
carbon dioxide at the moment most of
that carbon just gets emitted out of the
chimney the idea of carbon capture is to
take those fumes and run them through a
special unit which removes the co2 the
common can then be stored under the
ground in places like depleted oil and
gas fields as is planned in the north
sea or it can be put to use in other
industrial processes like chemicals
plants
that at least is the plan for this the
acorn project at some focus gas terminal
except as you can probably see it is
still just that a plan
which brings us to the main thing you
need to know about carbon capture
without it all those plans to get
britain's greenhouse gas emissions down
to net zero
won't work have you got any of those
scenarios that don't rely one way or
another on carbon capture no is the
short answer we have actually looked at
this question so in december we
published um five different scenarios
for getting to net zero each of them did
include carbon capture to varying
degrees
we did have a a scenario without it but
interestingly it it didn't quite get
there so without carbon capture
it's impossible is it it's not
impossible but it's much much harder i
think it can be done but it does rely
ultimately on the government putting
some big policies in place some of them
quite expensive
and
for me that's the bit that's missing at
the moment
then there's the second big issue it's
never been successfully implemented at
scale
travel the country and every so often
you encounter the ghosts of carbon
capture past here is one at the old
longanic coal-fired power station in
fife
there was a whole scheme it was going to
take all the fumes out of that chimney
and get rid of all of the carbon then in
2011 it was cancelled it was too
expensive
the power station is now being
dismantled
and further north in aberdeenshire peter
head gas fire power station spent
millions of pounds on a carbon capture
storage project cancelled in 2015.
so what's different this time around
the key difference at this time is the
government's legal commitment to achieve
net zero emissions across the whole of
the country the only way you can achieve
that particularly in these hard probate
industries is is to do carbon capture
use and storage this is a furnace where
you're burning natural gas another
difference is that the technology has
improved actually the main innovations
behind carbon capture have been around
for decades but new startups like carbon
clean say they can do it much more
efficiently their rig the blue one here
can do the same work maybe even more as
that enormous contraption behind it
this you can call miniature version for
a furnace or a power plant okay where
you are burning natural gas
and going straight away to a carbon
capture plant so it's going through all
these pipes and it's ending up with your
machine here correct where does the
captured co2 come out and it released
from the top from there
the co2 is just released into the air is
it yeah
it is released into the air okay
in other words even here at the very
cutting edge we're not quite there yet
with the clock ticking down to 2050
we're still a long way from big projects
that actually capture carbon and store
it and even leaving aside the concerns
about perpetuating fossil fuel use not
everyone is convinced until we get to
the point where there is a
a case for deploying carbon capture from
a commercial viewpoint carbon capture
will not happen
in the coming weeks tartar chemicals
will open this the country's first and
biggest industrial carbon capture
facility using that co2 to make sodium
bicarbonate and today the government
confirmed funding for two new clusters
capturing carbon in the northeast and
north west of england the averdington
scheme will be a reserve so its fate
still hangs in the balance but as world
leaders prepare for the crunch summit in
glasgow it is clear that for this
technology and the environment time is
of the essence ed conway sky news